all right good morning everyone my name
is Lex Frieden I'm a research scientist
here at MIT I build autonomous vehicles
and perception systems for these
vehicles and today I'd like to talk
first of all it's great to be part of
this amazing course and enter deep
learning it's it's a wonderful course
covering pretty quickly but deeply some
of the fundamental aspects of deep
learning this is awesome
so the topic that I'm perhaps most
passionate about from the perspective of
just being a researcher in artificial
intelligence is deep reinforcement
learning which is a set of ideas and
methods that teach agents to act in the
real world if you think about what
machine learning is it allows us to make
sense of the world but to truly have
impact in the physical world we need to
also act in that world so you bring the
understanding that you extract from the
world through the perceptual systems and
actually decide to make actions so you
can think of intelligent systems as this
kind of stack from the top to the bottom
so in the environment at the top the
world that the agent operates in and at
the bottom is the effectors that
actually make changes to the world by
moving the robot moving the agent in a
way that changes the world that acts in
the world and so from the environment it
goes to the sensors sensing the raw
sensory data extracting the features
making sense of the features
understanding forming representations
higher and higher order representations
from those representations we gain
knowledge that's useful actionable
finally we reason the thing that we hold
so dear as human beings the reasoning
that builds and aggregates knowledge
basis and using that reasoning form
short-term and long-term plans that
finally turn into action and act in that
world changing it so that's kind of the
stack of artificial intelligence and the
question is how much in the same way as
human beings we learn most of the stack
when we're born know very little and
would take in five sensory
sources of sensory data and make sense
of the world learn over time to act
successful in that world how much the
question is can we use deep learning
methods to learn parts of the stack the
modules of the stack or the entire stack
end to end let's go over them okay so
for robots that act in the world
autonomous vehicles humanoid robots
drones their sensors whether it's lidar
camera or microphone coming from the
audio networking for the communications
I am you getting the kinematics of the
different vehicles that's the raw data
coming in that's the eyes ears nose for
robots then the ones you have the
sensory data the task is to form
representations on that data you make
sense of this raw pixels or raw pieces
samples for whatever the sensor is and
you start to try to piece it together
into something that can be used to gain
understanding it's just numbers and
those numbers need to be converted into
something that can be reasoned with
that's forming representations and
that's where machine learning deep
learning steps in and takes this raw
sensory data the with some pre process
some process some initial processing and
forming higher and higher order
representations in that data that can be
reasoned with about in the computer
vision from edges to faces to entire
entities and finally the interpretation
the semantic interpretation of the scene
that's machine learning playing with the
representations and the reasoning part
one of the exciting fundamental open
challenges of machine learning is how
does this greater and greater
representation that can be formed
through deep neural networks can then
lead to reasoning to building knowledge
not just a memorization task which is
taking supervised learning memorizing
patterns and the input data based on
human annotations but also in extracting
those patterns but also then taking that
knowledge and building over time as we
humans do building into something that
could be called common sense into
knowledge basis in a very trivial task
this means aggregating fusing multiple
types of multiple types of extraction of
knowledge so from image recognition you
could think if it looks like a duck in
an image it sounds like a duck on the
audio and then you could do act activity
recognition with the video it swims like
a duck then it must be a duck just
aggregating this trivial different
sources of information that's reasoning
now I think from the human perspective
from the very biased human perspective
one of the illustrative aspects of
reasoning is theorem proving is the
moment of invention of creative genius
of this breakthrough ideas as we humans
come up with I mean really these aren't
new ideas whenever we come up with an
interesting idea they're not new we're
just collecting pieces of higher-order
representations of knowledge that we've
gained over time and then piecing them
together to form something some simple
beautiful distillation that is useful
for for the rest of the world and one of
my favorite sort of human stories and
discoveries in pure theorem proving is
for Moz Last Theorem
it stood for 350 years this is a trivial
thing to explain most six well eight
year olds can understand the definition
of the the conjecture that X to the M
plus y to the N equals e to the N has no
solution for N greater than three
greater than equal to three okay this
this has been unsolved there's been
hundreds of thousands of people try to
solve it and finally Andrew Wiles from
Oxford and Princeton had this final
breakthrough moment in 1994 so he first
proved in 1993 and then it was shown
that he failed and then so that's that's
the the human drama and then nightly so
he had he he spent a year trying to find
the solution and there's this moment
this final breakthrough three hundred
fifty eight years after this first form
of the by Pharma as a conjecture he he
said it was so incredibly beautiful it
was so simple so elegant I couldn't
understand how I'd missed it and I just
stared at it and just believed for 20
minutes
this is him finally closing the loop
figuring out the final proof I just
stared at it in bit disbelief for 20
minutes then during the day I walked
around the department and I keep coming
back to my desk looking to see if I was
still there it was still there
I couldn't contain myself I was so
excited it was the most important moment
of my working life nothing I ever done
nothing I ever do again will mean as
much so this moment a breakthrough
how do we teach neural networks how do
we learn from data to achieve this level
breakthrough that's the open question
that I want you to sort of walk away
from this part of the lecture thinking
about what is the future of agents that
think and Alexander will talk about the
new future challenges next but what what
can we use deep reinforcement learning
to extend past memorization passpack
pattern recognition into something like
reasoning and achieving this
breakthrough moment and at the very
least something brilliantly in 1995 and
after Andrew Wiles Homer Simpson and and
those are fans of The Simpsons actually
proved him wrong this is very
interesting so you found an example
where it does hold true the form a
theorem to a certain number of digits
after the period okay and then finally
aggregating this knowledge into action
that's what deep reinforcement learning
is about extracting patterns from raw
data and then finally being able to
estimate the state of the world around
the agent in order to make successful
action that completes at a certain goal
so and I will talk about the difference
between agents that are learning from
data and agents that are currently
successfully being able to operate in
this world example the agents here from
Boston Dynamics are ones that don't use
any deeper enforcement learning that
don't use any they don't learn from data
this is the open gap the challenge that
we have to solve how do we use
reinforcement learning methods build
robots agents that act in the real world
that learn from that world except for
the perception task so in this stack you
can think from the environment to the
effectors the promise the beautiful
power of deep learning is
taking the raw sensory data and being
able to an automated way do feature
learning to extract arbitrary high order
representations and that data so makes
sense of the patterns in order to be
able to learn in supervised learning to
learn the mapping of those patterns
arbitrarily
high order representations on those
patterns to to to extract actionable
useful knowledge that's in the red box
so the promise of deep reinforcement
learning why it's so exciting for
artificial intelligence community why it
captivates our imaginations about the
possibility towards achieving human
level general intelligence is that you
can take not just the end-to-end
extraction of knowledge from raw sensory
data you can also do end-to-end from raw
sensory data be able to produce actions
to brute force learn from the raw data
the the semantic context the meaning of
the world around you in order to
successfully act in our world and to end
just like we humans do that's the
promise but we're in the very early
stages of of achieving that promise so
any successful presentation must include
cats so supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning sits in the middle was
supervised learning most of the the data
has to come from the human they're the
insights about what is inside the data
has to come from human annotations and
it's the task of the machine to learn
how to generalize based on those human
annotations over future examples it
hasn't seen before and unsupervised
learning you have no human annotation
reinforcement learning is somewhere in
between close around supervised learning
where the annotations from humans the
information the knowledge from humans is
very sparse extremely sparse and so you
have to use the temporal dynamics the
fact that in time these the the
continuity of
our world through time you have to use
the sparse little rewards you have along
the way to extend that over the entirety
of the the temporal domain to make some
sense of the world even though the
rewards are really sparse those are two
cats learning Pavlov's cats if you will
learning to ring the doorbell in order
to get some food that's the basic for
them the reinforcement learning problem
so from supervised learning you can
think of those networks as memorizers
reinforcement learning is you can think
of them crudely so as sort of
brute-force reasoning trying to
propagate rewards into extending how to
make sense of the world in order to act
in it the pieces are simple there's an
environment there's an agent it takes
actions in that agent it senses the
environment so there's always a state at
the agent senses and then I always when
taking an action receives some kind of
reward or punishment from that world so
we can model any kind of world in this
way they can model an arcade game break
out here Atari break out the engine has
the capacity to act move the paddle it
has it can influence the future state of
the system by taking those actions and
it achieves the reward there's a goal to
this game the goal is to maximize future
reward you can model the cart pole
balance a problem where the you can
control the pole Angle angular speed you
can control the cart position the
horizontal velocity the actions of that
is the pushing the cart applying the
force to the cart and the task is to
balance the pole okay and the reward is
one at each time step the pole still
upright that's the goal so that's a
simple formulation of state action
reward you can play a game of doom with
a state being the raw pixels of the of
the game and the actions are moving the
the player around shooting and the
reward positive one at eliminating an
opponent and negative one agent is
eliminated
it's just a game industrial robotics any
kind of humanoid robotics when you have
to control multiple degrees of freedom
control the robotic arm control the
robot the
State is the raw pixels of the real
world coming into the sensors of the
robot the actions of the possible
actions the robot can take so
manipulating each of its sensors
actuators sorry actuators and then the
reward is positive when placing a device
successfully negative otherwise so the
task is to pick something up put it back
down okay so a and I'd like to sort of
continue this trajectory further and
further complex systems to think the
biggest challenge for reinforcement
learning is formulating the world that
we need to solve the set of goals in
such a way that can be a we can apply
these deep reinforcement reinforcement
learning methods so give you an
intuition about us humans it's
exceptionally difficult to formulate the
goals of life what is a survival
homeostasis happiness who knows
citations depending on who you are so
state the state sight hearing taste
smell touch that's the raw sensory data
actions are think move what else I don't
know and then the reward is just it's
open all these questions are open so if
we want to actually start to create more
and more intelligent systems it's hard
to formulate what the goals are with the
state space is with the action spaces
that's the that's if this the if you
take it away anything sort of in a
practical sense from today form from the
deeper enforcement learning part here a
few slides is that there's a fun part
and a hard part to all of this work so
the fun part the what this course is
about
I hope it's inspire people about the
amazing interesting fundamental
algorithms of deep learning that's the
fun part the hard part is the collecting
and annotating huge amount of
representative data in deep learning
informing higher representations data
does the hard work so data is everything
once you have good algorithms data is
everything and deep reinforcement
learning the heart the fun part again is
these algorithms we'll talk about them
today we will overview them but the hard
part is defining the world the action
space and the reward space now it's just
defining formalizing the problem is
actually exceptionally difficult when
you start to
to create an agent that operates in the
real world and actually operates with
other human beings and are actually
significantly helps in the world so this
isn't playing an arcade game where
everything is clean or playing chess go
it's when you're operating in the real
world everything is messy how do you
formalize that that's the hard part and
then the hardest part is getting a lot
of meaningful data that represents that
fits into that formalization that you
form okay in the the Markov decision
process that's underlying the thinking
of reinforcement learning there's a
state you take can actually receive a
reward and then observe the next state
so it's always state action reward state
that's the sample of data you get as an
agent acting in the world state action
reward state there's a policy where an
agent tries to form a a policy how to
act in the world so that it will never
state it's in it it has a preference to
act in a certain way in order to
optimize the reward there's a value
function that can estimate how good a
certain action is in a certain state and
there is sometimes a model that the
agent forms about the world a quick
example you can have a robot in the room
at the bottom left starting moving about
this room it's a three by four grid it
tries to get to the top right because
it's a plus one but because it's a
stochastic system when it goes chooses
to go up it sometimes goes left and
right ten percent of the time so in this
world it has to try to come up with a
policy so what's the policy is this a
solution so it's starting at the bottom
arrows show the actions whenever you in
that state that you would like to take
so this is this is a pretty good
solution to get to the plus one in a
deterministic world and it's the cast
the world when you don't when you go up
you don't always go up it's not a
optimal policy because you have to have
an optimal policy has to have an answer
for every single state you might be in
so this is the optimum policy would look
something like this now that's for when
the the cost the reward is negative
point zero one for taking a step now fee
every time I take a step it's really
painful
it's you get a negative to reward and so
there's a the optimal policy changes
there's no matter what no matter the
statistician a of the system the
randomness you want to get to the end as
fast as possible even if you go to
negative states you just want to get to
the plus one as quickly as possible and
then so the reward structure changes the
optimum policy if you make the reward
negative point one then there's some
more incentive to explore and as we
increase that reward or decrease the
punishment of taking a step more and
more exploration is encouraged until we
get to the kind of what I think of as
college which is you encourage
exploration by having a positive reward
to moving around and so you never want
to get to the end you just kind of walk
around the world without ever reaching
the end okay so there's a the main goal
is to really optimize reward in this
world and because the reward is
collected over time you want to have
some estimate of future reward and
because you don't have a perfect
estimate of the future you have to
discount that reward over time so the
goal is to maximize the discounted
reward over time and in q-learning
is an approach that that I'd like to
focus in on today the there's a state
action value queue it's a queue function
that takes in the state and action and
tells you the value of that state it's
off policy because we can learn this
function without forming a optimal
without keeping an optimal policy an
estimate of an optimal policy with us
and what it turns out with the equation
at the bottom or the bellman equation
you can estimate the you can update your
estimate of the Q function in such a way
that over time it converges to an
optimal policy and the update is simple
you have an estimate you start knowing
nothing the there's an old this estimate
of an old state Q SAT and then you take
an action you collect a reward and you
update your estimate based on the
awardee received and the difference
between what you've expected and what
you actually received and that's the
update usually walk around this world
exploring until you form better but
understanding of what is the good action
to take in each individual state and
there's always as in life and in
reinforcement learning in any agents
that act if there's a learning stage
where you have to explore exploring pays
off when you know very little the more
and more you learn the less and less
valuable it is to explore and you want
to exploit you want to take greedy
actions and that's always the balance
you start exploring at first but
eventually you want to make some money
whatever the the the metric of success
is and you want to focus on a policy
that you've converged towards that is
pretty good a near optimal policy in
order to act in a greedy way as you move
around with this bellman equation move
around the world taking different states
different actions you can update a you
can think of it as a cue table and you
can update the quality of a taking a
certain action in a certain state so
that's a that's a that's a picture of a
table there or in this the world with
four states and four actions and you can
move around using the bellman equation
updating the value of being in that
state the problem is when this cute
table grows exponentially in order to
represent raw sensory data like we
humans have when taking in vision or if
you take in the raw pixels of an arcade
game that's the number of pixels that
are there get is larger than is it is
larger than can be stored in memory is
larger that can be explored the
simulation it's exceptionally large and
if you know anything about exceptionally
large high dimensional spaces and
learning anything about them that's what
deep neural networks are good at forming
the approximator is forming some kind of
representation an exceptionally high
dimensional complex space so that's the
hope for deeper enforcement learning is
you take these reinforcement learning
ideas where an agent acts in the world
to learn something about that world and
we use a neural network as the
approximator as the thing that the agent
uses in order to approximate the quality
either approximate the policy or
approximate the quality of taking a
certain action in certain state and and
therefore making sense of this raw
information forming higher and higher
order representations of the raw sensory
and for me
in order to then as an output take an
action so the neural network is injected
as a function approximator into the
queue it's it's the cue function is
approximated with a neural network
that's DQ n that's deep Q learning so
injecting into the Q learning framework
and your own network that's what's been
the success for deep mind with the
playing the Atari games having this
neural network takes in the raw pixels
of the Atari game and produces actions
or values of each individual actions and
then in a greedy way picking the best
action and the learning the loss
function for these networks is twofold
so you have a you have a Q function an
estimate of taking a certain action
certain state you take that action and
then you observe how it's the actual
reward received is different so you have
a target you have a prediction and the
loss is the squared error between those
two and DQ n has uses the same network
the traditional DQ n the first ya DQ and
uses one network to estimate both Q's in
that loss function a double D Q and d DQ
n uses a separate network for each one
of those a few tricks their key
experience replay so it tricks in
reinforcement learning because it's the
fact that it works is incredible and as
a fundamental sort of philosophical idea
knowing so little and being able to make
sense with from such a high dimensional
space is amazing but actually these
ideas have been around for quite a long
time and a few key tricks is what made
them really work so in the first I think
the two things for D queuing is
experience replay is instead of letting
the agent learn for as it as it acts in
the world agent is acting in the world
and collecting experiences that can be
replayed through the learning so the
learning process jumps around through
memory through the experiences and
instead so it doesn't it doesn't learn
on the local evolution of a particular
simulation
that learn of the entirety of its
experiences then the fixed target
network as I mentioned with GG QN the
fact that the loss function includes if
you notice sort of two two forward
passes through the neural network and so
because when you know very little in the
beginning it's a very unstable system
and bias can I can have a significant
negative effect so there's some benefit
in for the target the forward pass the
neural network takes for the target
function to to be fixed and only be
updated then you'll now work there to be
only updated every thousand one hundred
steps and there is a few other tricks
the slides are available online there's
a few interesting bits throughout these
slides please check them out there's a
lot of interesting results here on this
slide and showing the benefit that you
get from these tricks so replay
experience replay and fixed target
network are the biggest that's the magic
that's the thing that made it work for
the atari games and the result was
achieving with deepmind achieving super
above human level performance on these
atari games now what's it's been very
successful use now with alphago and the
other more complex systems is policy
gradients which is a slight variation on
this idea of applying your own networks
in this deep reinforcement learning
space so DQ one is Q learning you'll
know what can the Q learning framework
it's off policy so it's approximating Q
and infer the optimal policy policy
gradients PG is on policy is directly
optimizing the policy space so the
neural network is estimating the
probability of taking a certain action
and the learning and there's a great if
you want the details of this from Andre
Botha is a great post explaining
illustrated in an illustrative way
deeper enforcement learning by looking
at pong playing pong so the training
process there is you look at the
evolution of the different games and
then reinforced also knows actor critic
you take the policy gradient
increases the probability of good action
and decrease the probability of bad
action so the policy network is the
actor so the neural network is the thing
that takes in the raw pixels usually a
sequence of frames and outputs a
probability of taking a certain action
so you want to reward actions that have
eventually led to a winning a high
reward and you want to punish the you
want to decrease you note of negative
gradient for actions that that led to a
negative reward so the the reward there
is the critic the policy network is the
actor the pros and cons of DQ on of
policy gradients was DQ n most folks now
the success comes from policy gradients
active critic methods different
variations of it the the pros are its
able to deal with more complex Q
function as faster convergence in most
in most cases given given you have
enough data that's the big con is its
needs a lot of data and use a lot
ability to simulate huge huge amounts of
evolutions of the system and because the
model probabilities the the policy of
grading smaller the probabilities of
action they're able to learn stochastic
policies and DQ lung cannot and that's
where the game of Go has received a lot
of successes with the application of
policy gradients where at first
alphago 2016 beat the top humans in the
world at the game of go by training an
expert games so in a supervised way
starting from training on those human
expert positions and alphago 0 in 2017
achieving a monumental feat and an
artificial intelligence one of the
greatest in my opinion in the last
decade of training on no human expert
play playing against it itself being
able to beat and the initial alphago and
beat the best human players in the world
this is an incredible achievement for
reinforcement learning they captivated
our imagination of what's possible with
these approaches but the actual approach
and you can look through the slides as a
few interesting tidbits in there but the
it's using the same kind of methodology
that a lot of game engines
I've been using and certainly go players
for the Monte Carlo tree search so you
have this incredibly huge search space
and you have to figure out like which
parts of it do I search in order to find
the good positions the good actions and
so there you'll now actually use to do
the estimation of what are the good
actions what are the good positions
again the slides have the fun the fun
details for those of you who are
gambling addicts
this is importantly so the the
stochastic element of poker at least
heads-up poker so one on one has been
for the first time ever this same exact
approach have been used in deep stack
and other agents to beat the top
professional poker players in the world
in 2017 the open challenge for the
community for maybe people in this room
in 2018 is to apply these methods to win
in a much more complex environment of
term and play when there's multiple
players so heads-up poker is a much
easier problem the human element is much
more formal izybelle and clear there
when there's multiple players it's
exceptionally difficult and fascinating
a fascinating problem that's perhaps
more representative of agents that have
to act in the real world so now the
downer part a lot of the successful
agents that we work with here at MIT and
build the robots that act in the real
world are using almost no deep
reinforcement learning so deeper
enforcement learning is successfully
applied in context of simulation in
context of game playing but in
successfully controlling humanoid
robotics or human robots humanoid robots
or autonomous vehicles for example the
deep learning methods they use primarily
for the perception tasks they're
exceptionally good at making sense of
the environment and extracting useful
knowledge from it but in terms of
forming actions that's usually done
through optimization based methods
finally a quick comment on the
unexpected local pockets that's that's
at the core of why these methods are not
used in the real world here is a game of
coast runners where a boat is
asked with receiving a lot of points
traditionally the game is played by
racing other boats and trying to get to
the finish as quickly as possible and
this boat figures out that it doesn't
need to do that in a brilliant
breakthrough idea it can just collect
the regenerating green squares that's an
unintended consequence that you can
extend to other systems perhaps
including you can imagine what how the
the cat system over time at the bottom
right can evolve into something
undesirable and further on in these
reinforcement learning agents when they
act in the real world the human life is
often the human factor are often
injected into the system and so
oftentimes in the reward function the
objective loss function you start
injecting concepts of risk and even
human life so what does it look like in
terms of AI safety when an agent has to
make decision based on a loss function
that includes an estimate or risk of
killing another human being this is a
very important thing to think about
about machines that learn from data and
finally to play around as there's a
there's a lot of ways to explore and
learn about deeper enforcement learning
and we have at the URL below there a
deep traffic simulation game it's a
competition where you get to build a car
that speeds that tries to achieve the as
close to 80 miles per hour as possible
and I encourage you to participate
participate and try to win get at a
leaderboard not enough MIT folks are at
the top 10 so with that thank you very
much thank you for having me
[Applause]